bon je m'appelle sautons patrie que je
travaille conseil général de mg je suis
responsable
des sites privilégiés comme la villa
jardin étant au palais on a travaillé un
projet pour faire émerger talent à la
villa bon le conseil donné il faut
réfléchir avant d'agir fait situer
l'endroit peut faire 1 1
un mur végétal on a travaillé dessus une
structure sens mais de l'appui des sur
un mur qui devrait pas fait la que
fait on a travaillé avec des tubes carré
quand tu pars et près de mieux apprendre
on a travaillé les structures tous les
deux fait on est la première phase pour
solidifier le mur donc on met les tripes
à ras terre pour faire un socle de béton
assez épais comme ça le les poteaux
tiennent comme des photos son hôte donc
fait mieux quand même assez solide
commence de rien et puis voilà essaye de
faire le maximum pour voir ce que ça va
donner
au revoir quand même à savoir faire
et puis faut être un peu fou connaître
la maçonnerie tout ça la prochaine étape
c'est monté la cascade les tuyauteries
et ici dans un petit bassin en cascade
qui tombe dans le bassin
on a commencé par par fondation montreux
et après montre de la structure
métallique
on a déjà prévoir de monter les gabians
les gabions c'est comme des paniers pour
remettre la semaine à lyon a progressé
les gabions maîtres effet pas c'est le
tube goutte à goutte comme un gentil
appui dans tous les cas bien comme étant
une programmation su combien de temps de
leur dos combien ne pas jouer encore une
fois pas osé et après les gabions on va
s'installer dessus de celui objets
talent on va travailler avec les plantes
qui aiment au soleil et ombre
les choix des plantes on n'est pas
encore fixé mais on a déjà des idées il
faut bien cibler l'endroit où me mettre
des plantes fait on peut permettre une
plante qui qui s'est tous fait environ
80 qui grandissent un mètre cinquante de
mire végétal sera vendu tous faut
choisir les plantes on peut permettre de
fougères dans mes objets talent c'est
normal mais un couvent envoyé médical
mais les fougères il faut mettre déjà
mes véritables avec un soutien aux fêtes
avec un morceau de tôle publié de
koupéla est un peu tôt l'invasion mêlera
mois la racine pénètre pas dans la
semaine
de notre côté
on peut travailler au fait ensemble âge
avec de la récupération
si vous avez un des trois filles de
trois pieds 1 3 grillage on peut
construire avec un petit et un tuner
digital est tranquille au même dans une
coopération des boutures et repiqué d'un
mur végétal et à des stratégies d un mur
végétal si on met des plantes qui m dos
en bas il va prendre l'eau et vous me
mettez les plantes un peu et un pas trop
le apéro au moins tout le reste d'eau
qui va descendre en bas peuvent être
faites
on prend des plantes pour mettre un
méritas pour le payage vous donne des
couleurs
mary talent c'est comme quelqu'un qui
peint un tableau c'est un artiste du
pana tableau mais merson bout à son
inspiration